aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler du
square de la roquette au coeur du 11ème
arrondissement de paris ça m'arrive de
passer devant à pied mais je n'y rentre
quasiment jamais dedans c'est très
agréable
il ya plein de jeux d'enfants et en les
sortant même rigolé mais cela n'a pas
toujours été le cas parfois il suffit de
se renseigner sur ces endroits on passe
souvent devant sans faire gaffe pour se
rendre compte que derrière il y à de
drôles de l'histoire l'histoire que je
vous raconte remonte au 19e siècle en
1836 pourrait plus précis et à ce moment
là le square de la requête n'existe pas
je connais un square en fait le square
de la roquette
à la place c'est une prison qui
s'appelle la petite roquette et c'est
une prison pour mineurs
et accrochez-vous bien l'acheter détenu
va de 6 à 20 ans il ya 500 cellules
individuelles et une architecture
inspirée de jeremy bentham qu'on a déjà
vu ensemble dans une vidéo vous mais un
rapide extrait pour vous rappeler de
quoi je parle lui c'est jeremy bentham
c'est un philosophe anglais avec son
disciple john stuart mill c'est le papa
de l'utilitarisme mais en tant que
précurseur du libéralisme
il a aussi beaucoup travaillé sur les
libertés individuelles il est aussi
connu pour un concept la panoptique
c'est un modèle architectural de prison
en gros on a un observateur au milieu
qui peut voir l'intérieur de toutes les
cellules et détenus ne peuvent pas voir
si le gardien les regardent ou non et
donc ils se sentent constamment observés
c'était une idée qui avait pour but de
réduire les coûts de la prison puisqu'il
fallait du coup moins deux gardiens pour
surveiller les prisonniers
michel foucault s'est aussi intéressé à
ce concept dans surveiller et punir et
en gros il nous dit que pour lui ce
principe de panoptique entraîne un
assujettissement réel ce que ça veut
dire c'est que l'observé devient
vraiment soumis à l'observateur et que
ça ça cause du déséquilibre vu s revu
ses théories nous montre une chose parce
qu'on ait observé
on perd une partie de notre liberté
le sentiment d'être observé réduit
considérablement notre champ d'action
pour être isolé davantage même la
promenade journalière d'une petite heure
par jour
ce fait seule la prison n'avaient pas
d'électricité du coup elles n'étaient
pas chauffées et donc certains enfants
mourraient de froid on avait un taux de
mortalité annuelle d'environ 15% quant
aux lettres qu'ils envoyaient à leurs
parents elles étaient détournés et du
coup on retrouvait des lettres comme ça
par exemple tu sais que ça fait au moins
cinq lettres que je t'écris et que je ne
reçois aucune lettre de toi alors
l'excusé de la lettre détourner ses
excuses qu'on peut plus sortir à ses
parents malheureusement la petite
roquette a fermé en 1932 pour devenir
une prison pour femmes
et finalement elle a été détruite en
1974 c'était ya moins d'un siècle et
pourtant aujourd'hui cette prison elle
nous semble inhumaines et horrible à tel
point que quand je l'aï appris j'ai eu
envie de vous en parler après elle nous
semble totalement aberrante notamment
parce qu'on est familier avec une notion
spéciale de justice pour mineurs
mais ça n'a pas toujours été une
évidence dans le droit romain ou même
moins loin dans l'ancien régime
il n'y a pas de justice pour mineurs et
majeurs les deux sont jugés de la même
façon en fait en france on a un tribunal
pour enfants et adolescents depuis 1912
et surtout on a un juge des enfants
depuis une ordonnance de 1945 qui du
coup visiblement ne savais pas à quel
seuil doliprane la grande différence que
ça apporte c'est qu'à partir de 1945 on
décide clairement que l'éducatif prime
sur le répressif et ça c'est un gros
changement parce qu'en fait mine de rien
c'est admettre que les mineurs peuvent
changer et qui sont pas condamnés à être
des criminels
est ce que c'est vrai ça en fait pendant
longtemps on avait une vision
héréditaire des choses qu'on va appeler
l'inegi sme est celui qui a porté sa il
s'appelle cesare lombroso dans un livre
qui s'appelle l'homme criminelle il
avance le concept de criminel né est en
fait il va comparer les formes de corps
les formes de crâne et cetera de gens
qui sont condamnés à la guillotine est à
remarquer des ressemblances
par exemple les gens ont généralement de
longs bras donc en gros il dit si tu as
de l'ombre à ta plus de chances d'être
délinquant
voilà évidemment ça a été vachement
critiquer j'aurai la durée dit et son
bouquin plein de fois en changeant plein
de trucs et c est l'un de ceux qui le
critiquaient le plus c'était alexandre
lacassagne qui au début était vachement
d'accord avec lui et ensuite plus du
tout pour lui c'est l'environnement
social qui est le terreau de la
criminalité et c'est pour ça qu'il a une
phrase qui est très puissante
j'adore les sociétés ont les criminels
qu'elle mérite
mais pour savoir s'il ya vraiment une
hérédité au lieu de se baser sur des
formes de crâne
on va faire de vraies études
scientifiques y en a pas mal qui par
exemple ont étudié des adoptions
d'enfants qui étaient dans un milieu
problématique avec de la criminalité et
qui se retrouvent dans un milieu sans
tout ça on a fait aussi plein d'études
sur des jumeaux
j'en reçois des vrais jumeaux soit
défaut jumeaux donc par exemple savez
plus de paires de vrais jumeaux qui
avait un comportement problématique que
deux paires de faux jumeaux ça pouvait
laisser penser que l'hérédité avait un
rôle important à jouer
on a fait toutes ses études et en 2002
il ya une étude de riz et wegmann qui
analyse toutes ces études là ils en sont
venus à la conclusion que bien que le
background génétique peut avoir une
forte influence sur les comportements
problématiques l'environnement a une
influence encore plus forte
ce qui signifie que même si des
individus ont de forte prédisposition il
pourrait ne jamais commettre de délit
s'ils ne sont pas exposés à certains
facteurs environnementaux et j'avoue ça
va embêter de trouver ces résultats en
fait parce que j'aime pas me dire que
yens part d'hérédité là dedans j'aime me
dire qu'on n'a pas à subir notre
hérédité et pourtant c'est totalement
faux et à cette étude par exemple
meta-analysis of the heritage city of
human rights baizen fifty years of queen
stade et est à ce moment qu une analyse
meta de toutes les études de jumeaux
donc sur 50 ans donc on parle de 14
millions de paires de jumeaux sur 39
pays et les résultats sont hyper clair
je cite
nos résultats montrent irréfutablement
que tous les traits humains sont
héréditaires
pas un seul trait à une hérédité estimée
à 0 concernant le sujet qui nous
intéresse tous importants précisé qui a
pas un gène de la criminalité
en fait c'est plusieurs gènes qui sont
liées par exemple à la dopamine à la
sérotonine à la noradrénaline en fait
c'est des gènes qui sont plutôt
responsable de l'agressivité ou
l'impulsion et pour info cette
conjugaison à la fois génétique et
environnementale
elle a donné un champ d'étude qui est la
criminologie bio sociale mais même si
elle est deux genres génétique et
environnement ça m'embête de pas savoir
à quel point l'environnement est
beaucoup plus fort que la génétique
comme le dit l'étude de riz et wiseman
est en fait pour ça pour une expérience
faudra un endroit où j'en mets plein de
prisonniers et genre des années plus
tard
on regarde si l' indice de criminalité
est élevé mais genre à l'échelle d'un
pays
genre sur plusieurs siècles ce serait
fou ça vous est pareil l'australie pour
comprendre pourquoi je vous parlais
l'australie faut revenir un petit peu
sur son histoire et notamment son
histoire de colonisation c'est une
cotisation des britanniques et ça a
commencé par la nouvelle galles du sud
et non c'est pas du tout une maladie de
la peau
c'est ici que ça se passe voilà le
premier truc qu'ils ont fait c'est la
fondation d'un camp pénitentiaire avec
736 prisonniers apport jackson sydney en
fait alors pourquoi commencer par une
prison et pas en fait pour régler les
problèmes de surpopulation des prisons
anglaises
le gouvernement britannique a décidé de
faire de l'australie une colonie
pénitentiaire
c'est un mot un peu complexe pour dire
prison géante alors le transport de
bagnards en nouvelle galles du sud
il s'arrête en 1840 mais ça continue
jusqu'en 1868 pour l'australie
occidentale
bref en gros je l'avais courte sur 80
ans il ya 160 mille bagnard qui sont
transportés en australie ça fait
beaucoup et donc du coup aujourd'hui on
estime que 20 % de la population
australienne et descendantes de détenus
ce qui est énorme a du coup c'est
intéressant de regarder son indice de
criminalité et bâle indice de
criminalité et de l'australie il est
assez faible en fait en 2020 il environs
de 41 et fun fact c'est plus faible que
celui du royaume uni qui d'ailleurs fun
fact est plus faible que celui de la
france
bref en termes de sûreté du coup c'est
le 56e pays sur 129
mais avec 20 % de la population qui
descend de détenus on pourrait
s'attendre à un autre chiffre est en
fait non ce qui est quand même je trouve
pas mal rassurant c'est une vidéo que je
voulais quand même vous montrer parce
que j'ai l'impression que dans le climat
giner collectif dans le match in et
versus acquis sur ce sujet et peut-être
que je me trompe pas c'est l'impression
que j'avais mais j'avais l'impression
que sur ce sujet tout le monde pensait
que tout se joue au niveau de la cuisse
et l environnement et qu' il n'y avait
pas de poids au niveau ligne c'était ma
conception du truc et j'avais
l'impression qui a été partagé
j'imaginais pas qu'un criminel puisse
l'être pour des raisons génétiques quoi
et en fait il ya un impact de l'ine
aussi qui est modéré qui est à remettre
dans un contexte qui est beaucoup moins
fort que l'environnement mais qui existe
arch précise ça n'excuse rien ça ne
déresponsabilise rien puisqu'on voit que
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut dépasser
mais ça existe
je trouve que quelque part là dedans il
ya quelque chose d'inspirant quoi on
peut avoir une sorte de fardeaux
génétique et pourtant le dépasser et
aller au delà et donc finalement je
trouve que le message de ces études de
ces chiffres et moi ce que j'ai retenu
de tout ça en fait en en plongeant un
petit peu dans cette question c'est que
on peut dépasser une forme de
déterminisme par la volonté en se créant
un environnement sain et en se prenant
en charge
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu je
mets le lien des études en descriptions
j'ai un autre sujet de vidéos qui je
pense va faire et quoi celui là je la
ressortirai dans quelques semaines et
donc celle là c'est presque une partie 1
par rapport à ce que je vais dire après
je crois encore une fois n'hésitez pas à
me suivre sur instagram
@ cyrus nord et sur twitch voilà je vous
donne plus mon planning de live parce
que en ce moment le planning change un
petit peu car je chante en farine
expérience vous en parlerai évidemment
sur youtube voilà prenez soin de vous
love peace ciao